sonia pour toi j'ai créé les sauniers
awa on va regarder des vidéos en rapport
avec les miss ou les séries télé
d'accord c'est toi qui nous dira avec
bien sûr béatrice qui a gagné son torse
et les sonia et béatrice aux voix avec
le sony howard du moment malaison dans
une élection de miss
regardez bien les nommer son regarde
hilux lors de la première élection de
miss france à la télé ou est ce que nous
en sommes attendez nous avons donc donné
la 4e' la 5e temps des 4e dauphine la
troisième dauphine la deuxième
la deuxième dauphine on est en mesure de
l'affirmer complètement d'une façon très
sincère c'est joël ramia de la réunion
2e dauphine c'est à dire qui est classée
troisième dans votre classement par des
effectivement je sais là où j'habitais
là non et en fait il ya une grosse
erreur l'a43 oh là là ça y est nous y
sommes à kehl à petra vous êtes en train
de nous mettre mon cher équipé il se
froncent 89 submergé par l'émotion
nous allons donc découvrir dans un
instant qui est miss france 1989
miss miss miss c'est un suspect miss
aquitaine
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et steve harvey l'animateur de miss
univers 2015
[Musique]
à leur tour à la défense en europe et ce
colombien
mais ce duo nos boss tout à une pts
[Applaudissements]
leur palette dans la grande carcasse à
lille ça j'en reparle maintenant la
grande carcasse a dit ranger cas
exceptionnel ça devient je pense voilà
je vous le dire on n'a jamais autant
risque en fait l'heure leur système
n'est pas le même que le nôtre avis
d'appel à première dauphine et du coup
c'est là où lui c'est une foule s'est
planté wells ah ah ouais bien sûr parce
que chez nous en fait dans l'émission ce
qui se passe et ça me rend fou à chaque
fois la pauvre la deuxième dauphine à
l'appeler la troisième dauphine la
quatrième de la pop dauphine tout le
monde sur la tête de même hervé sauf
qu'ils arrivent c'est qu'à la fin
d'année deux comme ça se tiennent comme
ça ouais et toumodi me je pensais tout
le monde se jette sur miss france c'est
la pire place mon père va tenter
d'éliminer 30e frères même afin de venir
au musc d'être première dauphine
première dauphine frère tu as une soirée
droit tu fais le truc où maintenant le
jeu dans les yeux comme ça mais nie
qu'il aime bien la meuf et genre t'es
content pour elle c'est elle et lui
maintenant doté du don doc est l'est de
la région paca taux n'a rien à [ __ ]
il la regarde comme ça ça va être toi
non ça va être toi n'ont pas noté michel
aurait loisy et voilà dont luc lui je
connais tu m'as dit ça me mènera sera
moi j'étais premier dauphin à l'aquaparc
mais aussi dans les sodas c'est quoi le
moment plus gênant pour toi et on s'est
cassé suite steve harris est horrible
parce que en plus à l'abattoir vécu le
truc mais la couronne tatum et la mairie
comme si tu avais la fève et comme cela
et aux filous tollé de la fête des fous
ça à l'école un jour j'ai eu la fève ils
m'ont enlevé le fait pour une hymne au
lever la fête
je n'ai jamais triché et voilà
[Applaudissements]
je vous aurais fais moi quand j'étais
petit on faisait la galette des rois
même la fera si j'avais ramené mcef de
chez moi ennahdha et je voulais cinéma
déjà 6 ans j'étais là on s'est fait avec
moi j'ai pas fais cobas et je dis à ces
mois tu l'as fait
après ils ont dit y avait deux faits ils
ont ils ont délaissé les autres galettes
avait pas de fête avec eux dans la
mienne ça lui qui a triché j'ai dit
franchement c'est pas beau hein
isabelle chaque année elle croit qu'elle
aime c'est donc ainsi qu'une version a
très bien compris ça c'est un bon moment
le sauna world du roman gênant dans une
série télé les nommés sont regardés
[Musique]
la comédienne qui n'a pas vu le mur non
s'il vous plaît si c'est pour une
dédicace
tu as maintenant j'ai vraiment pas le
temps canon ce prêt pour dédicacer paul
et félicitations
pour la firme watson quant à vous vous
êtes à changer d'une femme parce que la
tension y est
[Applaudissements]
et au gaumont de plus belle la vie ce
qui fait que cette merde au et les
actrices d'un moment interminables dans
la série la belle-mère
bonsoir
bon
[Applaudissements]
pour vous c'est quoi c'est le dernier
bye ben ouais ça doit rigoler sur le
problème moi j'aime bien le mur aussi
mais je fais j'aime bien les chutes en
général mais ouais mais c'est vrai que
ça c'est le lait change le plus long le
dos à dos au mur on le veut on le donne
mais enfin dernier dernier accède pour
le sony howard de la nuit ce que l'on ne
comprend pas ce lien vous frappez auquel
années elle a été nommée miss en 2000 en
2006 le 6 décembre 11 décembre 90 la 70e
à la mairie à la mêlée à l'hôtel de
ville de paris
il a lu mon instinct non pas du tout non
pas du tout il a rien à [ __ ]
et ce mec il n'a pas lu ton instagram
amis je pense 2002 et qui est battante
on regarde
miss provence 2015 ah ouais
c'est un accélérateur de vie je pense
que durant une année de miss france on
ne serait pas capable de pouvoir vivre
ce qu'on serait capable de vivre
je ne veux pas miss côte d'azur 2013
qu'est ce que cette arrivée au col de
vous faire comme la france c'est un
carrefour historique
un trait d'union sud et nord je suis le
fruit de la rencontre entre l'angleterre
et l'italie
je suis fier d'être métis européenne et
de parler couramment la langue de
shakespeare et i30 et je fais des études
en langues étrangères appliquées
suite à mon diplôme je souhaite intégrer
l'école de théâtre à paris miss quercy
rouergue où 2003 je veux montrer à toute
la france que j'adore de vivre et je
veux voir le bonheur dans chaque oeil de
chaque spectateur
merci beaucoup et moselle
[Applaudissements]
radio caire top 5 il a tout et joe perdu
jusqu'à la mer ça je mettrai lewarde à
jean-pierre il est gentil moi qui les ai
jean pierre méhu c'est un amour ah bah
ouais mais il commence bien sûr
l'émission retrouve jean pierre foucault
21h15 sur tf1 ce sera samedi avec mon
ami jean-pierre foucault bien entendu et
ça même moi je vais regarder je suis me
faire une soirée faire une soirée
je fais de soirée avec mise alors on va
personnes envoient des sms mois